- (Interviewer) Alright, so Michael.
- Yes.
- (Interviewer) so your in a gang?
What gang, what's the name of the gang?
- (Michael) Lennox thirteen.
It is part of the LAX
Airport, its surrounded by the
airport, its a small little city.
It runs from Hawthorne to Englewood.
- (Interviewer) Oh its city of Lennox
- City of Lennox.
- (Interviewer) Yeah I heard.
- Yes
- (Interviewer) That's where you live?
- That's were I currently
live. Was living.
- (Interviewer) you were.
- Yes.
- (Interviewer) and what, what
is, at what age did you enter
the gang?
- At the age of eight.
- (Interviewer) eight years old?
- Yes
- (Interviewer) Wow, did you
do initiation when you get in?
And all that kind of stuff?
- Um...yeah.
- (Interviewer laughed)
- (Interviewer) And what does that intel?
- Just um, families. That
was part of why I got in.
- (Interviewer) Yeah you said
you knew the right people
to...
- Yeah.
- Well I was young though too
but I just wanted to be around
people that cared about me.
- (Interviewer) Tell me,
tell me about your childhood.
- My childhood?
- (Interviewer) Yeah, your parents.
- It was rough, my dad is in a gang.
My mom was never in my life.
- (Interviewer) Your mom was what?
- My mom was never in my life.
- (interviewer) Oh, you
mom was never in your life.
- Never in my life.
My grandma raised me.
- (Interviewer) Oh wow, really?
- Yeah.
- (Interviewer) So at eight
years old you... I I I mean.
So violence comes into
the picture at what point?
- At the age of eleven.
I started doing violence.
I went to California Youth Authority.
I did um, seven years.
- (Interviewer) For what?
- Um, attempted murder.
- (Interviewer) Really?
- Yeah.
- (Interviewer) At what age?
- At eleven.
So after eleven till eighteen,
like I was in and out.
So basically I did all my time
in and out till I was like
eighteen years old.
Then got out, been on
file, been on placement,
been through all that.
- (Interviewer) Did you
go to school while you...
- While, while I was in, well
when I hit prison at the age
of twenty-one.
When I got out when I was
twenty-five years old.
That was my first term,
um, I was but my mind
wasn't focused on school, my
mind was still doing things for
the benefit of the gang.
But on my second term I did go to school.
I went to school but I didn't
finish it because I got
discharged from prison.
And I've only been out
for like three years.
- (Interviewer) Where do
gangs basically abide by?
Its abide by?
Controlling?
- (Michael) Controlling streets,
and um, and um, money wise
its all about money.
Money and drugs.
- (Interviewer) Drugs too?
- (Michael) Drugs.
- (Interviewer) Did
you ever use drugs? Or.
- (Michael) When I was
younger, but I, I haven't used
for a long time.
- (Interviewer) So how
many guys are in your gang?
- (Michael) Approximately,
right now we are looking at like
approximately 125, 100 members.
- (Interviewer) Wow.
What kind of ages that are there?
- (Michael) The youngest
right now is thirteen.
but majority's from thirteen and up.
But there's nothing but
youngsters right now.
- (Interviewer) you grew up in East LA?
- (Michael) No I grew up
in um, West Los Angeles.
- (Interviewer) Where's that at?
- (Michael) City of Lennox.
- (Interviewer) Yeah okay
so off by the Airport.
And so do you ever talk to
your mom, or dad, or whoever
you stand out to.
- Yeah I talked to my mom once in a while.
Um, my dad I don't talk to him.
- (Interviewer) He was in a gang as well.
- Yes.
- (Interviewer) So you were,
you were following your dads
footsteps.
- Basically, but not his, I've
seen, but not basically his.
I lived in an area were my uncle was from.
And when he passed away
I went on, I took over,
I went, got on you know?
- (Interviewer) So your
uncle was in a gang as well?
- Yes.
- (Interviewer) And then, so
like today how old are you now?
- Right now I'm twenty eight.
- (Interviewer) twenty eight?
Inside the gang is there like a hierarchy?
Or some people are like in control?
- Yes.
- (Interviewer) More powerful.
- (Interviewer) Interesting, cool.
Well thank you so much for talking to me.
- (Michael) Your welcome.
- (Interviewer) This is
your... your baby over here?
- My step daughter.
- (Interviewer) Your step daughter?
- Yeah.
- (Interviewer) Well
thanks for talking to me.
- All right thank you.
- (Interviewer) You have a great day.